ja es geht um die cdu in deutschland die
steht von der epochalen neuen
entscheidung sowie 1969 oder 1998 wird
die cdu in neustadt brauchen um sich
aufzustellen das hat der bundesvorstand
der cdu heute auf den weg gebracht es
gibt es endlich einen klaren fahrplan
und es gibt eine linie wo die mitglieder
beteiligt werden das ist ganz wichtig
weil wir den kreis positionen besprechen
ob sie mitgliederbefragung geben soll
und wollen dann spätestens im januar auf
einem bundesparteitag einen komplett
neuen vorstand der cdu wählen vom
bundesvorsitzenden generalsekretär über
die stellvertreter über des präsidiums
mitglieder und über den bundesvorstand
dann ist die cdu neu aufgestellt und
dann muss schluss sein mit
personaldebatten damit endlich und die
inhalte in diesem land wieder gesprochen
werden kann da braucht es auch eine
bürgerliche konservative partei die
abbott erhebt die sich nicht nur mit
sich selbst beschäftigt
absolut sie haben ja die frage die ich
stellen wollte schon eigentlich auch mit
rein geworfen es geht nicht und personal
es geht um inhalte und das ist im
wahlkampf vermisst habe und den die cdu
leider auch in den letzten jahren waren
inhalte konservativer inhalte eine
alternative zu diesel
diese linke politik die vor allem bei
den linken bei den grünen bei der spd
auch eine riesen platz bekommen haben
dass das video eine alternative ist
bürgerliche konservative haltungen die
leider mit der politik berkel
verschwunden sind und ich hoffe dass in
diesem prozess nicht nur über personal
und neuer positionen die besetzt werden
sondern vor allem um inhalte diskutiert
werden ich glaube ja herr mohring
sind ihren optimismus toll dass sie
glauben dass es einen geordneten
neuanfang geben muss für die cdu hätte
ich jetzt wahrscheinlich welche
cdu-mitglied wäre oder in
als abgeordneter so wie sie genau so
gesagt aber ich glaube die beiden sachen
schließen sich aus geordnet und neu
anfangen wenn man neu anfangen will auch
mit neuer kreativität alte ausgetretene
pfade verlassen möchte was neu ist auch
richtig erschaffen möchte dann glaube
ich kann man das nicht von oben
operieren dann kann man das nicht von
oben lenken und steuern dann muss das
von unten kommen dann braucht es
kreativität und wir haben es auch
gesehen bei der vorgängerin von armin
laschet frau kramp karrenbauer die
diesen prozess der erneuerung von vorne
wie sie mann sagte führen wollte das hat
nicht geklappt und das zweite wo ich ihn
leider auch keine hoffnung machen kann
ich glaube dass das ein sehr langer und
schmerzhafter prozess würde ich glaube
nicht dass wenn die union einen neuen
parteivorsitzenden hat wie auch immer
gewählt ob der mitglieder oder parteitag
im januar das dann quasi alle gräben
zugeschüttet sind und dass man dann
sagen kann jetzt wissen wir wo wir
hinwollen das glaube ich nicht sie haben
die beispiele genannt 1969 das 13 jahre
gedauert bis die union wieder an die
regierung kam 1998 hat da noch mal
sieben jahre gedauert also ich glaube
das ist wird ein sehr langer und
schmerzhafter prozess für ihre partei
ich bin gar nicht widersprechen das
haben sie an den epochalen ereignissen
auch gemerkt dass die genannt habe aber
sie sind notwendig dass wir erst mal ein
geordnetes verfahren kommen was den
letzten wochen nach dabei erlebt haben
war ja quasi ein hühnerhaufen es war
alles durcheinander jeder hat dem
vorschlag gemacht jeder ist gut gemeint
aber es gab keine ordnung mehr und das
ist das gefährlichste für seine partei
den anspruch volkspartei zu sein die
führungslos wahrgenommen wird und heute
war wichtig dass die führung sich wieder
verständigt auf dem verfahren und das
prinzip umkehrt und sagt wir wollen
unsere basis für nicht der
bundesvorstand schlägt jetzt vor wie es
weitergeht sondern bundesvorstand sagt
die basis kommt zusammen die
kreisvorsitzenden zunächst immerhin 330
an der zahl und die sagen ob sie in der
mit ihrer befragung machen wenn die das
wollen gibt's eine da gibt es später
etwas drei tagen für sind sie ich bin
für der mitte befreien also die 400.000
mitglieder sollen entscheiden wer wird
der nächste partei scheint diese sollen
befragt werden mit der entscheid gibt es
nicht in der cdu der bundesparteitag
will den vorsitzenden aber es ist der
parteitag ist gut beraten sich an ein
votum einer mit der befragung zu
erhalten wenn es hoffentlich klar
ausgeht man muss nur wissen es ist kein
allheilmittel wermes gesehen bei der spd
die haben olaf scholz nicht gewählt
haben zwei andere gewählt die wurden den
wahlkampf versteck der andere wurde
kanzler oder wird kanzler vermutlich
erfolgreich ja aber liegt auch an der
schwäche der anderen und nicht nur an
dem prinzip wie es die spd gemacht hat
und wir aber der cdu in baden
württemberg gesehen die sind zwei mal so
ein prozess durchlaufen und waren
hinterher nicht so einig wie man es
braucht damit man erfolgreich politik
machen kann entschädigung sind in der
israelischen
geschichte nein wir haben uns
disziplinierten wissen jetzt wird die
ampel verhandelt und nur wenn die ampel
scheitert dann steht die cdu zur
verfügung wir haben heute nochmal
bundesvorstand besprochen dass wir genau
diese verantwortung wissen und wenn
ampel scheitert steht die cdu bereit für
schon mal kann aber nicht das schiff
aber wenn die ampel jetzt scheitern im
november beispielsweise scheitert sie es
geht nicht weiter und wie geht es dann
weiter dann hat die cdu noch keinen
neuen chef aber einen der vier wochen
später geht 5 die sich warm laufen mit
wem genau soll dann beispielsweise
annalena baerbock mit wem soll christian
lindner hat dann in der cdu verhandeln
gerne bleiben die beiden parteichefs die
ansprechpartner armin laschet und markus
söder und dann wird im wechsel im
laufenden verfahren im januar es an der
parteitag wird dann während der
laufenden jamaika sondierungs und
koalitionsverhandlungen ein neuer cdu
chef gewählt wenn es dazu käme wäre das
dann so wenn es verfahren so eingebildet
ist dann ist das so aber ich bin
trotzdem richtig dass armin laschet
jetzt für sich sagt ich moderiere diesem
prozess er ist nicht zurückgetreten dass
der unterschied zum letzten jahr als ak
für sich gesagt hat sie tritt zurück und
dann will sie den prozess in folge
führen ich glaube jetzt hat auch die
lasche daraus gelernt dass es gut ist es
am zu haben die autorität des amtes auch
zu haben und trotzdem diesen prozess zu
begleiten und dann auch im geordneten
übergang hin zu kriegen und es wird ja
in geordneten übergang geben weil es
würden neuen parteichef geben aber
danach ist sehen wir noch nicht durchs
wasser durch sei ganz klar wir sind
vermutlich in der opposition und wir
haben die große auswahl müssen dann eben
auch wieder fit sein um die ampel könnte
auch noch friedrich merz der
bundeskanzler werden in dem szenario
oder carsten linnemann oder jens spahn
oder ralph brinkhaus oder habe ich noch
jemand vergessen beispielen für den sie
denn oder lord nennen sie jetzt die
union neu aufstellen müssten für wen
werden sie der in einem zukünftigen
bundeskanzler sind ja einige namen
gefallen ich glaube für keinen von von
den ohne dass wir uns böse sind also ich
glaube jetzt sparen als ehemalige
krankenschwester kann noch er ganz wenig
als kanzler vorstellen
da möge man mir nicht böse sein warum
ihre meinung sagen machen wir immer alle
ich habe nichts dagegen die meinung zu
sagen also ich glaube dass
das mir dass noch mehr deals braucht
kein mensch also wir hatten jetzt masten
deals wir haben dinge die
organisatorisch nicht geklappt haben ich
begrüße es wenn sie sich neu sortieren
und neu aufstellen und da kommt bestimmt
was tolles bei rum wenn sie sagen armin
laschet soll was lernen er soll alles
lernen was man lernen kann damit das
benutzen kann und das finde ich eine
schöne idee habe ich die frage was
spannend also
wenn man die uhren nach erneuerung und
jamaika ist noch nicht vom tisch was
meinen sie wirklich ernst das ist glaube
sie glauben dass die olaf scholz ist
nicht hinbekommt mit den grünen und der
fdp zusammen eine koalition zu zimmern
das habe ich das nicht gesagt schon fast
so lange ich vom tisch solange wie die
ampel nicht unterschriftsreif fertig
verhandelt ist ganz klar aber wenn der
sozusagen die außensanierung herausgehen
in die ampel koalitionsverhandlungen ist
das für die cdu erst mal erledigt es sei
denn die ampel schaltet an sich im
regierungshandeln aber es wird halt mich
auf die cdu kommt deshalb an weil dann
wichtig ist hält die fdp ihre
versprechen ein was die frage steuern
betrifft keine steuerung zu machen weil
die fdp versprechen ein was die
schuldenbremse betrifft sind ja alles
wichtige fragen oder lassen sich von der
klammer grünen spd sage nein quetschen
um der regierung will und das ist ja
nicht unspannend dafür braucht seine cdu
die aufmerksam ist die mit ihren
inhalten durchdringend ich teile das ja
aber sie sagen wir dringen wir unseren
inhalten deshalb nicht durch die letzten
zwei jahre weil wir nur noch mit
personalfragen beschäftigt sind vor der
wahl nach der wahl dann hoffentlich
endlich im januar auch erst einmal die
kanzlerin haben die inhalte nicht im
vordergrund sagt gesetzt hat das ist
natürlich eine ansichtssache würde ich
mal sagen ich finde angela merkel werden
wir noch vermissen als bundeskanzlerin
ist nicht gesagt dass sie sich von
angela merkel alles partei auch
emanzipieren wird das nichts mit ein
neuer anfang das wird ja passieren für
meinung es gibt ja diese epochale bruch
der jetzt stattfinden wird die
kanzlerschaft ist dazu ende auf der 1
dazu kommt jetzt noch die
oppositionsrolle die ja so nicht
angestrebt war aber stattfindet das
macht ja was mitmach partei und er muss
sich neu aufstellen für die zukunft wenn
sie wiedergewählt werden will muss sie
mehr mit liefern als 24 prozent im osten
sogar mehr als 20% mitbringen darf nicht
vergessen was bei uns passiert ist in
den neuen ländern ist ja quasi
existenzielles existenzbedrohend für
viele als parteistruktur weil man so
nicht mehr volkspartei status abbilden
kann in der muss die cdu sich neu und
stärker aufstellen ich kann sie aber
trösten ich komme aus einer sehr kleinen
sehr skurrilen oppositionspartei
opposition macht spaß aber ich aber herr
mourinho
am ende muss man scheint der der der von
der bundeskanzlerin dass dieses projekt
selbst bestimmt aus dem amt zu scheiden
das hat doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht
funktioniert ist doch ein scherbenhaufen
den sie jetzt hinterlässt
das projekt ist gescheitert in der 2 der
anspruch von angela merkel immer zu
sagen
kanzleramt und parteivorsitz gehört in
eine hand das ist im dezember 2018
aufgelöst worden seitdem tun wir uns ja
auch schwer mit der nachfolgedebatte
weil das kanzleramt auch in der hand
geblieben ist von angela merkel und der
parteivorsitz mehrmals gewechselt ist da
sieht man dass es offensichtlich klug
war es vorher anders zu betrachten und
das aus der hand zu geben hat vieles
ausgelöst aber eben auch das darf man
nicht vergessen das ist ebenso knappe
personalentscheidungen gegeben hat auf
dem parteitag und manchmal fragt man
sich wer das ausgegangen wenn damals
nicht ak geworden hätte sondern
friedrich merz oder jens spahn hättest
dann überhaupt den dominoeffekt der
nächsten entscheidung gegeben laufen
sehen dass die cdu das ist gut dass ruhe
einkehren wird die eu solange in spa
nicht parteichef ist
ich hoffe dass alle die es kandidieren
wissen dass es darauf ankommt die
ergebnisse anzuerkennen wenn sie denn
gefällt sind es wird spannend man darf
nicht vergessen es geht um die frage des
parteivorsitzenden es geht um die frage
des generalsekretärs geht um die frage
des fraktionsvorsitzes
das muss man ja sehen ich kann meiner
partei nur empfehlen diese pakete
insgesamt zu betrachten um befriedung
hinzukriegen sonst reden wir im januar
über den parteivorsitz antreten im märz
über den fraktionsvorsitz fangen dann
wieder ein mit denselben leuten noch
also ein paket wer wird parteichef wird
generalsekretär wer wird
fraktionsvorsitz das als ein paket
abzustimmen ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass die partei wenn sie dann
abschließend entscheidet damit der
befragung und dann auf dem parteitag das
bedeutet ja viel sympathie haben wenn
jemand kommt und der sagt ich würde hier
so die gesamtpaket anbieten auch die
hand reichen eine andere mitbewerber um
sozusagen so ein vorschlag zu machen
kann mir vorstellen dass es funktioniert
[Musik]